the 2020 Oscars are here but what did
Hollywood's biggest night look like at
the turn of the millennium he T's taking
a look back at the 13 wildest moments
from the 2000 Oscars I'm gonna wake up
in the morning and go somebody was
playing a joke on me you know Angelina
Jolie won Best Supporting Actress for
her role in Girl Interrupted it was
really shocking and so nice it was her
first Oscar nom ever I may never be back
here so I'm just having fun
Angie's brother James came along as her
plus-one he was my brother you have got
to be so happy for her I am so proud and
I'm so happy this is the best day of our
lives and the two caused quite the stir
when they were photographed kissing on
the mouth how great is it to have him
with you at all these shows he's the
most amazing accessory he's your good
luck charm ah yeah oh he's just but he's
just so beautiful to me he's just yeah
he makes me look good what I mean he's
just he makes everything okay you know
he just holds my hand I just had my head
in his shoulder and I knew that didn't
matter what happened because I was just
safe right here Lucy Liu also brought
her brother introduced us she took the
stage at the Oscars to present the award
for best costume design alongside
Cameron Diaz and drew Barrymore who were
there to promote a little movie called
Charlie's Angels good morning angels
we're hearing all kinds of stories about
the action sequences that you guys are
doing with Charlie's Angels get what can
you tell us that there are a lot of fun
it's a lot of work we all have bruises
all over our bodies therefore I have no
slit and this is a very long dress it's
like all of a sudden you realize you
discovered it like you have another
instrument I can use my body in a way
that I never allowed myself to do
and I finally I'm getting paid to do it
it's an amazing thing to be able to kick
butt and like go for it and yeah Drew
was there with her then-boyfriend Tom
Green I thought I'd come hang out with
my gorgeous girlfriend yeah Wow Jennifer
Aniston and Brad Pitt were still a
couple who's gonna be your date Nick is
she's shooting but I I hope that you
know she'll get the time off and so were
Nicole Kidman and Tom Cruise pretty
excited who was nominated for Best Actor
in a supporting role that year who was
the first person you called yeah I
called Nick what's she saying she was
really excited Billy Crystal was the
host for the 7th time and in sync
performed at the big show how do you
feel about performing and run out this
crowd excited to be here we're such fans
of all the people who are here so I mean
we're like kids in a candy store right
now little out of our element who have
you seen that you were so excited to see
so far everybody judge then there was
Matt Stone and Trey Parker the creators
of South Park it's a night of magic it's
a magical night and we're just so happy
to be a part of it
yeah the two came dressed as JLo from
the 2000 Grammys and Gwyneth Paltrow
from the 1999 Oscars Jennifer Lopez
we've got going on I don't know I just
wanted something special for the magical
night it's a night of magic then couple
Melanie Griffith and Antonio Banderas
were in attendance are you proud of your
mommy in Antonio
did you help mommy pick out her dress
no I'm do that that's Melanie's daughter
Dakota Johnson yeah
like fifty shades of gray Dakota Johnson
Anastasia Christian first of all I think
this is the most beautiful outfit at the
Oscars right here Haley Joel Osment was
just 11 years old
are you nervous and was nominated for
Best Actor in a supporting role for the
Sixth Sense are you ready for this I saw
you working the crowd over there it's a
nerve wracking going over and meeting
all the screaming fans no it's not
nerve-racking they're very supportive of
the film and I'm just having a great
time seeing of all what are you gonna
tell your friends about this night how
do you describe tell them everything
they're very curious but you know
there's a lot of coverage of it all the
cocaine was also nominated for Best
Supporting Actor for his role in The
Cider House Rules I have an attitude to
this is it's already decided so I can't
control it they're not paying me and
they can't fire me so what the hell am I
getting scared about if I get it it'll
be for survival in old age I think
that's what it'll be
and he took home the high honor it was
great then there was Hillary Swank
don't forget I'm nominated for Best
Actress she won Oscar gold for her role
in boys don't cry it's just the night of
your lives or what no our wedding night
walk and she forgot to thank her husband
at the time Chad Lowe did you forget to
thank him the most important can you
believe it
you know it's the one person that I
didn't you know write down a little list
because I thought you know he's my
husband I'm not gonna forget and then I
did well how do you guys celebrate
tonight um we're gonna go to some
parties and we're gonna go to an IHOP
somewhere
[Music]